some people claimed it was a miracle a
humpback whale was spotted in Montreal's
St Lawrence River this young whale had
swam almost 500 km Upstream in fresh
water it was first spotted just several
days after the city of Montreal reopened
after being hit by a soul crushing first
wave of covid-19 infections and
lockdowns but was this really a CO
Miracle there are certain types of
marine mammals that do just find in
freshwater and in saltwater Florida's
manatees are totally happy either way
but Marine whales and dolphins have skin
adapted to cope with dense salt water
exclusively if you toss it in a river
the less dense fresh water gradually
invades the collagen fibers and skin
cells if the animal can't find salt
water again soon the skin will inflate
so much that it Bubbles and bursts like
a third degree burn if you put them in
fresh water they actually do just die